so jetzt kommen wir aber zu aktuelle
stunde beantragt von der afg fraktion da
geht es um den arbeitsplatzabbau oder
den drohenden arbeitsplatzabbau in der
automobilindustrie
die aktuelle stunde ist eröffnet und der
ersten redner kommt von der afg als
antragstellenden fraktionen und ist es
rainer kraft
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsident wird die
kollegen die hätte zuschauer
produktionsrückgang um 12%
exportrückgang um 15 prozent so sei die
halbjahresbilanz der automobilindustrie
im ersten halbjahr 2009 10 aus doch
bereits in 2018 ist die produktion in
deutschland um 9,3 prozent gesunken
die branche befindet sich also im
zweiten jahr in folge im niedergang und
mit ihr alles was daran hängt daher ist
diese aktuelle stunde dringend notwendig
und was hängt daran
ich sage es ihnen in 2018 hat die
automobilbranche in deutschland 400 26,2
milliarden euro umgesetzt
der gesamtbeitrag des kraft
verkehrssektors im deutschen
steueraufkommen beträgt über 90
milliarden euro pro jahr
das ist jeder vierte euro im
bundeshaushalt 800.000 arbeitnehmer
zählt die branche und tippe noch die
indirekt abhängigen arbeitsplätze hinzu
so wird diese zahl auf 1 8 millionen
arbeitsplätze erhöht selber noch
verwandte und familie hin so sind wir
bei circa drei millionen menschen deren
wünsche erwartungen und hoffnungen
hätten daran hängen dass diese frauen
und männer auch weiteren mit ihrer
eigenen hände arbeit in stolz und würde
für den eigenen lebensunterhalt und den
ihrer lieben sorgen können
diesen menschen hat diese regierung den
kampf angesagt
es ist offensichtlich dass die deutsche
automobilbranche ein zentraler sektor
der gesamten deutschen wirtschaft ist
und das fortbestehen diese industrie ist
von elementarem interesse für unser land
und gerade an diese lebenswichtige
industrie legt diese bundesregierung auf
brutalste weise die axt an zunächst
stimmen die regierungsparteien in der eu
einer desaströsen co2 emission ordnung
für unsere pkw zu dann bevor sie eine
maßlos überzogen die stickoxid debatte
die uns letztes jahr hier beschäftigt
hat am ende wurde dieses vermeintliche
problem nicht mit praktischen maßnahmen
gelöst sondern durch ein stück papier im
parlament ein reales problem hat also
wohl nie existiert trotzdem haben sie
diese debatte für einen geradezu
religiösen feldzug gegen das auto
benutzt
der notwendigen diskussion über eine
reform der erhebung der stickoxid werte
sind sie dabei aus dem weg gegangen
überhaupt beschleicht mich bei ihrer
verkehrspolitik das gefühl man selbst am
muffigen tisch eines kommunistischen
planwirtschaft komitees in der
öffentlichkeit gelobt die
bundesregierung technologieoffenheit
ideen hat sie sich aber längst
festgelegt strom getrieben und mit
zentner schweren akkus ausgerüstet soll
das auto von morgen sein
dieses prinzip ist verwaltung war schon
mit dem benz patent motorwagen nummer
eins überholt aber wie man auch an ihrem
fetisch für windmühlen sieht steht die
technologisch antike bei dieser
regierung ganz ganz hoch im kurs
zurück zur planwirtschaft eine million
elektroautos hatten sie bis 2020 geplant
wo sind die denn auf unsere straßen
jedenfalls nicht also erhöhen sie nun
die prämien und die wohlhabende
rot-grüne bourgeoisie kann ihre
politisch korrekten zweitwagen vom
steuerzahler finanzieren lassen
der normale arbeitnehmer die aufs geld
schauen muss kann sich diese grünen öko
spiele 10 spielzeuge gar nicht leisten
internationale studien zeigen jedoch
dass diese art von auto in der
umweltbilanz verheerend ist für sie
spielt das aber keine rolle denn das
zentralkomitee hat sich festgelegt also
fließen die subventionsgelder und die
umwelt echt und muss diese unterstützung
bei wirklich alternativen und
umweltfreundlichen lösungen wie ios es
gibt sie nicht
sie wollen lieber drei milliarden euro
an steuergeldern für ladestationen
verpassen
3 milliarden und das für elektroautos
die es gar nicht gibt null euro werden
synthetische kraftstoffe für 43
millionen real existierende pkw
investiert das ist politik zum
davonlaufen und genau das tun immer mehr
menschen jedes jahr kehren
hunderttausenden leistungsträger diesem
land den rücken
das ist ihnen nur um ideologie gibt
zeigt sich auch darin wie co2 emissionen
gemessen
beim verbrennen entsprechen diese dem
realen verbrauch beim elektroauto werden
sie willkürlich auf null gesetzt die co2
emission der hälfte und dabei
unterschlagen co2 frei gibt es aber
nicht co2 armen können sie seien im
falle von e-autos wenn der strom was
verlässlichen zum beispiel nuklearen
quellen stammt aber co2 frei ist eine
firma aus dem politischen märchenland
sie wollen sie wollen für unser land die
große transformation und die wird leider
auch stattfinden
nur nicht so wie es den bürgern
verkaufen wollen wenn ihre politik der
dekarbonisierung nicht gestoppt wird
werden sie unser land wirtschaftlich auf
das niveau eines entwicklungs oder
schwellenland es hinab transformieren
mit der sozialismus immer getan hat
da wird dann kein geld mehr da sein für
umweltschutz und die menschen die sie
mit ihrer politik arbeitslos machen
werden sich auch nicht über umweltschutz
unterhalten und nachdenken wenn sie vor
den tafeln in der schlange stehen weil
sie keine warmen mahlzeit mehr leisten
können für diese menschen kämpfen wir
diese menschen müssen wir vor ihre
politik schützen
dafür sind wir hier angetreten wir
lassen es nicht zu dass unser land im
öko sozialismus versinkt und immer mehr
menschen in unserem land sind dabei an
unserer seite an ihrer jedenfalls nicht
und das ist auch gut so
bilder
das wort hat der parlamentarische
staatssekretär thomas bach ist der
präsident in meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren die aktuellen meldungen der
automobilbranche in der tat sowohl in
deutschland europa als auch in der welt
nehmen wir sehr ernst und schauen wir
auch mit gewissen sorge entgegen aber
dennoch während andere branche kaputt
reden und niedergang vor innenangriff
lektor schadenfroh sind geht die
bundesregierung dieses thema konstruktiv
an um geht's offensiv an und versucht
gemeinsam mit der branche die zukunft zu
gestalten hat ist richtige weg für
deutschland und hier auch sagen das wird
sich deutsche automobilbranche auch
nicht kaputt reden dürfen
wir haben deutschland eine hervorragende
autobranche sind trotz eines schwierigen
marktumfeldes noch sehr erfolgreiche
haben wir die letzten acht jahre über
110.000 beschäftigte neu in der
automobilbranche in deutschland erfahren
sind in europa derzeit marktführer sind
derzeit in europa ein
produktionsstandort der herausragend ist
wir haben heute die lage das selbst
länder wie deutsche 36 länder wie
frankreich italien spanien england die
haben große ordination waren insgesamt
weniger autos produzieren als
deutschland auch das zeigt wie stark der
uni standort deutschland derzeit ist wir
sind marktführer als marktführer im
bereich der premium fahrzeuge über 80
prozent der premium fahrzeuge weltweit
kommt aus deutschland und wir haben
sogar selbst dieses schwierigen
marktumfelds trotzdem haben wir die
marktanteile in der welt weiter stetig
erhöht auch das zeigt wie stark wir
unsere starke unsere branche haben und
es zeigt auch dass wir die richtigen weg
sind wir haben in deutschland sichere
effiziente und auch hochwertige
fahrzeuge und die waren der welt gekauft
und es sind auch weiterhin so bleiben
dafür arbeitet auch diese
bundesregierung eine serviette namen ein
helm kann trotzdem
gewissen verfehlungen und auch schwarze
schafe der branche stehen wir uns die
menschen im mittelpunkt die 840.000
beschäftigt natürlich mittelpunkt der
tat hat arbeiten hoch innovativ sind die
leistungsträger sind die auch zu
beitragen dass wir im wohlstand wachstum
in diesem land auch leben dürfen und die
auch jeden tag dafür sorgen dass die
bestellung auch weiterhin in deutschland
und der welt auch halten liegt auch das
ein ganz ganz wichtiger punkt und diese
menschen dürfen auch stolz auf ihre
produkte auf ihre hoch innovation und
auf ihre ingenieurleistung auch diesen
ganz ganz wichtige punkte in die
bundesregierung in besonderer weise
unterstützen auch teilten deshalb sind
wir auch generell stolz auf unsere
produkte die wir weltweit verkaufen
ich muss schon sagen einsortieren
gegangen der branche geredet oder auch
logisch in haftung genommen andererseits
gibt es auch durchaus auch personen die
sehr respektlos nach unverfroren mit dem
geschäft in der branche umgeht welche
weise winfried herrmann in baden
württemberg sagt die verkehrswende heißt
die bedeutung des autos zurück zu
drängen auch dessen ganz ganz falsche
ansatz den wir hier in schönheit
zurückweisen und ich sage deutlichkeit
ist der gipfel der unverfrorenheit wenn
auch jene günther hier in berlin sagt
wir möchten dass die menschen das auto
abschaffen auch das ist ein ganz ganz
tolles signal und da wollen sprechen
halten und sagen dass wir es einen
dasselbe brauchen auch zukünftig
fahrzeuge mobilität und da muss
deutschland eine ganz besondere
herausragende rolle spielen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren wir wollen
von seiten der bundesregierung
wirtschaft und beschäftigte unterstützen
in ihrem strukturwandel gestalten wir
wollen verantwortung übernehmen dann
auch die letzten paar monate haben
gezeigt dass wir gerade auch hier auch
vorreiter sind
deutschland hat ein einzigartiges
netzwerk von herstellern und zuliefern
70 prozent der produkte der teil heim
autokäufen herstellung von zuliefern und
ich glaube dass die allein die tatsache
dass 50 prozent der zulieferer
pharma-unternehmen sie in wohlstand und
zeigt auch dass da eine enorme
innovationskraft gerade auch im
ländlichen raum und so fläche sind
dachte ist das was für uns eine sehr
sehr wichtige politische wirkung hat die
wir für unsere weichenstellungen im
sommer racing mittelpunkt aufstellen und
die kombination aus großen kleinen
flexibilität innovationskraft zeigt dass
wir auch da eine steuer gehören die
herausragende sind auch dazu geführt
dass der standort deutschland auch wenn
es für unternehmen aus den usa wie tesla
auch der richtige ist um zu investieren
und auch das war ein starkes signal für
den standort wohingegen tester aber auch
zeigen muss dass innovation und
profitabilität und redete auch wirklich
zusammen passen auch hier haben
deutschland letztes jahr schon mehr
geleistet und haben gezeigt dass sie
profit und innovationen gemeinsam
verbinden können
natürlich stellt die branche vor großen
herausforderungen wir müssen einiges
nächsten jahr fälligen wahrscheinlich
größten herausforderung der geschichte
wir müssen einerseits die kurzfristigen
konjunkturellen themen auch angehen die
nachfrage in china aber es ist etwas was
unsere autohersteller besonders
beschäftigt - 6 prozent in diesem jahr
elektronische -30% wir haben die
konflikte handelskriege auch da brauchen
wir freie märkte offene märkte auch
diesem thema ist es um trägt und müssen
aber auch sehen dass auch teilweise
managementfehler inhalt joanneum
passiert sind auch das ist was uns
manchmal auch mit sorge bereitet aber
brauchen eine langfristige strukturelle
antwort auf die herausforderer zukunft
themen die nächsten jahr angegangen
werden müssen auf den themen schon
angegangen
wurden und für uns sowieso insofern
haben und themen an die wird ein
besonderer ist nochmal auch in mit punkt
dieser regierungsarbeit ein thema ich
das hier bei der antriebstechnik elektro
und wird die nächsten jahre eine große
rolle spielen wir haben ja
verschiedenste punkte gesprochen wir
haben gesagt dass wir hier eine sexy der
ladeinfrastruktur der bundesregierung
sehen wir haben über sieben bis zehn
millionen pkws die nächsten jahre die
wir aufbauen werden und elektro
mobilität und darauf eine ladenfläche
ist die stark ist und spendern auch für
eine ordentliche versorgung der zukunft
sorgt wir haben die kaufprämie ist 125
verlängert auch die sorge dass die
elektroautos hab da noch einmal
entscheidend unterstützt werden und wir
werden auch und dessen ganz ganz
wichtige funktion uns investieren werde
über eine milliarde euro den nächsten
jahres investieren um die
wertschöpfungskette auch der batterie
zellfertigung deutschland auch zu
positionieren wir haben da einen ganz
ganz besonderen bereich der den nächsten
jahren noch mal wichtig wird der
entscheidend sein wird und auch hier
werden wir sorgen dass die batteriezelle
fordern wir zurück kommt nach
deutschland
und da auch starke wieder auch entsteht
und wir auch in der batterie zeitung und
wieder einen ganz entscheidenden anteil
in der welt auch für uns reklamieren
auch da sind wir derzeit ganz konkret
die nächsten wochen werden auch die
entscheidungen hier für die unternehmen
und regionen getroffen und es zeigt auch
dass das wirkung hat nicht nur die
aufgaben der bundesregierung auch dass
die unternehmen machen und ich will auch
sagen dass wir da auch schon heute
erfolgreich sind ein drittel der patente
im bereich der kommt aus deutschland
auch das zeigt dass wir hier schon
zukünftig gut aufgestellt sind und dass
wir auch hier die richtigen welchen
schon auch gestellt haben aber weiter
und haben ich sage auch da nicht allein
elektroauto wird das antrieb der zukunft
sein
nach daten die offenheit nach 33
einsätze brauchen auch die batteriezelle
die brennstoffzelle brauchen wir
flexible jahres habe um eine wasserstoff
heute geht's auf den weg gebracht der
jedermann ganz neuen ansatz liefert auch
gerade nicht nur in den pkws und auch in
den lkws
wir brauchen auch noch zukünftigen
effizienten motor 8 ist eine rolle
spielen
weltweit transport sechs jahren noch
auch da möchte ich dass deutschland auch
weiterhin marktführer bleibt und wir
auch dafür sorgen dass die besten autos
aus deutschland kommen die besten
trainer schon kommen dass diese und
benzin auch entsprechend am
effizientesten auch zukünftig eingesetzt
werden ein weiterer megatrend der
zukunft ist natürlich auch schon
erfahren und für nächstes fahren auch
hier sind wir in der weltspitze und
weltmarktführer technologieführer auch
hier passiert viel wir haben wir die
letzten jahre enorm viel gefolgt seien
schon in die rechte ordnung fahren gegen
60 millionen euro aus unser ministerium
aus in die forschung entwicklung braucht
es kommt 41 prozent der patente in der
welt für autonomes fahren verfahren
kommt alleine aus deutschland auch das
zeigt dass wir marktführer sind allein
aus deutschland 40 prozent die usa 30
prozent zeigt dass wir wirklich auch
einen großen schritt voraus sind auch in
sotschi strategie auch die ganz große
rolle des themas fahren ein ganz ganz
entscheidende schlüsselfunktion und nach
der wehr die nächsten jahre noch einmal
einiges neues erleben und werden auch im
bereich der standardisierung in europa
an der welt auch weiter voranschreiten
auch dass der schrittmacher dass wir
auch hier die standards für die
richtigen produkte der zukunft auch sind
also diese beiden großen megatrends
werden wir gestalten herausforderung
gestalten und ich glaube auch da werden
wir zeigen dass die autos der zukunft
auch aus deutschland kommen und wir
damit auch weiterhin auf eine gute
beschäftigung auch die nächsten jahre
meiner mobilität und freiheit wird die
nächsten jahr hoffentlich in der welt zu
nehmen auch wenn die autos nächsten
jahren zunehmen werden eine qualität
erfahren die sowohl im lkw also am pkw
bereich auch weiter den enormen
fortschritt halten muss wir müssten dies
möchten die beste umwelt
klimafreundlichkeit aus deutschland
heraus liefern können deshalb rufen auch
da eine enorm innovative politik gehören
wir vorlegen
in diesem sinne freue mich auf die
kommende herausforderung und wie gesagt
jetzt packen wir es an geschlossenheit
und zuversicht gemeinsam auch ein finder
wir müssen die richtigen weichen stellen
fordert thomas bareiß der
parlamentarische staatssekretär beim
bundesminister für wirtschaft und
energie in dieser aktuellen stunde wie
arbeitsplatzabbau in der
automobilindustrie verhindert werden
kann
die aktuelle stunde wurde von der fdp
beantragt jetzt kommt oliver luksic von
der fdp fraktion ist er der
verkehrspolitische sprecher
die besten autos die meisten von uns
jedenfalls fahren auch gerne auto und
das muss so bleiben wir stehen vor einer
doppelten herausforderung zum einen das
thema der vernetzung wurde eben zu recht
an gesprächen über sprochen das muss
auch bei uns in den markt kommen und zum
anderen das thema der alternativen
antriebe und unsere kritik geht nicht
der e mobilität an sich steht ja für
urbane räume sinnvoll es gibt keine
direkten emissionen das thema lärm ist
positiv wenn eine eigene pv anlage auf
dem dach hat das passt da macht das auch
sinn aber uns stört der einseitige
planwirtschaftlichen focus durch quoten
durch subventionen und durch
strafzahlungen an herstellern deswegen
ist das in der tat ein
planwirtschaftlicher weg der
eingeschlagen wurde von regierung und
wir haben hier in der tat ein problem
weil derzeit wie man auf der einen seite
die strafzahlung haben die den
herstellern drohen die co2 flotten
grenzwerte und die subvention deswegen
muss das jetzt in den markt kommen ab 20
und das problem ist dass wir in
deutschland stark sind beim
antriebsstrang aber eben bei der
batterie ein stück wertschöpfung auch
verlieren werden weil nicht die gesamte
wertschöpfungskette bei uns abgebildet
werden wird weil wir hohe energiepreise
haben weil andere den zugriff auf die
ressourcen sich gesichert haben und dass
auch ökologisch fragwürdig ist und so
abhängig zu machen von lithium als
seltenen erden da hat china strategisch
einen fokus drauf und wir haben in der
tat bei den flotten grenzwerten dies
nicht einberechnet und deswegen ist das
ein problem weil die hersteller jetzt
autos verkaufen müssen die teurer werden
gehen sie aber kein geld mehr verdienen
deswegen haben wir diesen massiven
kostendruck bei herstellern zulieferern
und eine negative meldung die nach der
anderen kommt und deswegen ist diese
einseitige planwirtschaftliche fokus so
falsch der bisher an geschlagen wurde
wir müssen realistische und machbare
vorgaben haben zum einen bei den flotten
grenzwerten - 73 5 prozent bei den pkw
minus 30 prozent bei lkw das ist bei den
meisten noch gar nicht angekommen auch
die sollen elektrifiziert wenn das stößt
aber an technisch physikalische grenzen
des sinnvollen und sparen
das hat jetzt eben einen massiven
einfluss in der planung bei der
industrie- und dann kommt noch mal oben
drauf die strafzahlung 95 euro pro gramm
pro fahrzeug
das wird die industrie hunderte
millionen euro kosten und deswegen reden
jetzt alle über
arbeitsplatzverlagerungen und
arbeitsplatzabbau und das ist eben das
kernproblem kombiniert mit den
subventionen die staatssekretär bahr ist
eben ein gesprochen hat die eben sehr
einseitig sind sie geben milliarden nur
für eine technologie aus wollen eine
million ladepunkte bauen aber bei dem
thema brennstoffzelle da passiert eben
nicht sie setzten einseitig auf eine
technologie wir haben immer noch nicht
die schnellladestationen an den autobahn
von den lkws an den autobahn will ich
mal überhaupt nicht reden was sie machen
es planwirtschaft nur planwirtschaft
ohne plan und damit wirklich
technologieoffen ist wäre ist sinnvoll
und notwendig zb die beimischung bei
biokraftstoffen zu erhöhen wird nicht
gemacht öko diesel wird nicht zugelassen
es wäre sinnvoll of you zu setzen war
ein antrag im bundesrat von
schleswig-holstein synthetische
kraftstoffe hat die bundesregierung
nicht übernommen bei den verhandlungen
deswegen werden die eben nicht
angerechnet deswegen gibt es dazu keinen
anreiz und beim thema der
brennstoffzelle beim wasserstoff da wird
eben gekleckert und sonntags beim e
mobilitäts gibt es werden milliarden
ausgegeben für eine technologie und
montag beim wasserstoff gefühl wird eben
nicht gemacht und deswegen ist dieser
einseitige fokus der ist eben das
problem und deswegen wäre es auch mal
sinnvoll dass die auch mal wirklich mit
den ig metall facharbeitern reden ich
mach das schon auf einer veranstaltung
hat der örtliche bevollmächtigten wir
100 prozent recht gegeben
gehen sie mal mit den facharbeitern vor
ort und da gehen in der tat hoch
bezahlte arbeitsplätze verloren das
einstiegssegment die kleinfahrzeuge
werden verteuert fallen aus dem markt
deswegen ist das was derzeit passiert in
der tat doppelt und sozial gute
arbeitsplätze gehen verloren einstiegs
mobilität wird verteuert vor allem für
den ländlichen raum ist das nicht fair
und nicht gerecht und deswegen brauchen
wir in der tat eine strategie die auf
mehrere antriebsarten setzt die
technologie offen ist und das gegenteil
von dem was jetzt gemacht wird wir haben
einen ganz einseitigen fokus auf die
batteriegetriebene elektro mit der sorgt
dafür dass die industrie unter
kostendruck gerät dass arbeitsplätze
abgebaut und verlagert werden lassen sie
uns doch bitte unseren ingenieuren
vertrauen welche antriebe der zukunft
gebaut werden sie wollen dass dem
vorgeben wir sind der festen überzeugung
der staat ist nicht der bessere
autobauer lassen wir dass die kunden
lassen wir das die ingenieure
entscheiden was sie machen führt in der
tat zu einem massiven arbeitsplatzabbau
bei industrie bei zulieferern bei der
chemie beim maschinenbau bei allen
branchen die zusammenhänge im automobil
das ist eine schlüsselindustrie die an
die wir in der tat wieder denken müssen
hören sie auf die einseitig durch ihre
planwirtschaft schon vorgaben kaputt zu
machen
wie kann der umbruch und der
automobilindustrie also der wandel von
benzinern und dieseln hin zu
alternativen antrieben wie e autos so
gestaltet werden dass nicht so viele
menschen ihren arbeitsplatz verlieren
darüber diskutiert hier heute der
bundestag und als nächster spricht dazu
timon gremmels
franken wie afg fraktion beantragten
aktuellen stunde zum thema
arbeitsplatzabbau in der
automobilindustrie ausgerechnet an dem
tag an dem er macht verkündet hat im
großraum berlin eine tesla tiger factory
zu errichten mit bis zu 10.000
arbeitsplätze sollen hier entstehen
das ist der verdienst auch von die
brücke und der spd geführten
landesregierung in brandenburg das ist
ein gutes signal für den
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland für die
automobilindustrie für die facharbeiter
und vor allem sehr geehrte kolleginnen
von der at was war denn die gründe von
tesla sich für brandenburgs entscheiden
die verfügbarkeit von ökostrom können
sie genau eben insbesondere die
erneuerbaren energien und die windkraft
sind ein echter standortfaktor für
deutschland das war ein grund warum sich
allen macht für brandenburg entschieden
hat klimaschutz ist also ein
investitionsmotor es ist kein programm
zur idee industrialisierung deutschlands
wie sie von der afg immer hier überhaupt
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
das zeigt dass wir auf dem richtigen weg
sind zweitens die weltoffenheit der
metropolregion brandenburg warnt
wesentlicher weiterer bestandteil ich
kann sie nur appellieren gefährden die
nicht mit ihrer politik das die
weltoffenheit verloren geht und dass ich
das allein macht noch mal überlegt meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren dann
tragen sie dafür die verantwortung
ja was ist denn die höchste gefahr für
die automobil arbeitsplätze in
deutschland das ist nämlich die
abschottungspolitik beschaffungspolitik
ist der größte faktor der die
automobilindustrie gefährdet das sehen
wir an großbritannien
tesla hat sich auch gegen großbritannien
schienenwegen sprach sitz bmw hat seine
mini produktion gedrosselt weil der
branche droht ein drittel aller in den
vereinen im vereinigten königreich
tätigen automobil unternehmen habe
bereits jetzt arbeitsplätze abgebaut und
genauso eine nationale
abschottungspolitik verfolgt doch die
afg sie gefährden die
automobilwirtschaft in deutschland und
niemand sonst ja ja und immobilien
history steht in einem großen
transformationsprozess aber den können
wir nicht zurückdrehen weil wenn wir
jetzt abwarten und zurücklehnen dann
läuft uns china und andere länder vorbei
und dann gucken die arbeitnehmerinnen
arbeitnehmer in der automobilindustrie
in die röhre
wir müssen jetzt uns bewegen wir müssen
jetzt die innovativen arbeitsplätze bei
den automobil unternehmen auf den weg
bringen und es ist ja nicht nur treffler
gucken wir mal nach volkswagen auch
volkswagen hat ein e-mobil werk in
zwickau gebauten umgerüstet das ist
genau der richtige weg und auch bei mir
im vw werk kassel in baunatal in meinem
wahlkreis sind die belegschaft dabei
gemeinsam diese transformation zu
gestalten und der dortige
betriebsratsvorsitzende von volkswagen
hat gesagt ist er stolz auf seine
engagierten kolleginnen und kollegen
sind die während des wandels des
standorts hin zu einem mobilitäts werk
tat am anlauf mitgearbeitet haben die
sind nämlich unsere partner die
arbeitnehmerin und arbeitnehmer bei
diesen wandel die müssen wir mitnehmen
wir müssen den wandel gestalten und uns
dem nicht verweigern meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren und der
größte standort vorteil der größte
standort vorteil für die
automobilwirtschaft ist die betriebliche
mitbestimmung das müssen wir auch das
müssen wir deutlich sagen sie brauchen
gar nicht so zu geifern frau wer schreit
hat unrecht und die schreiben die ganze
zeit über eine reederei nicht bitte das
zu unterlassen
ich sage ihnen die betriebliche
mitbestimmung und eine funktionierende
tarif partnerschaft sind der
entscheidende standortvorteil für
deutschland das müssen wir auch tesla
sagen auch da erwarten wir dass das gut
bezahlte arbeitsplätze sind dass die
mitbestimmung da funktioniert auch das
muss man allen macht an so einem tag
heute sagen
und ehrlich gesagt
natürlich gehört ist auch dazu dass wir
gerade für den schwerlastverkehr nicht
nur e mobilität in den fokus nehmen wir
brauchen auch dort alternativen wie zb
energy wie zb die brennstoffzelle wie zb
fuels wie zum beispiel auch erdgas das
ist all das für den schwerlastverkehr
auch da müssen wir voranschreiten und
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
von der afg wenn es ihnen wirklich um
industrielle arbeitsplätze hier in
deutschland gehen würde dann hätte wäre
mir in dieser woche ein anderes thema
eingefallen wo sind denn in dieser woche
die größten und die meisten
arbeitsplätze abgebaut worden
beziehungsweise wo war es der die
ankündigung beim thema windkraft beim
thema windkraft fallen allein bei
enercon über 3000 beschäftigte in
ostfriesland und magdeburg ab dafür habe
ich von ihnen keinen wort hier gehört
das ist zynisch und das entlarvt ihrem 6
punkten sicher gemacht haben eine sehr
warten damen und herren und ich sage
ihnen ganz klar und deutlich
die partei der arbeit ist und bleibt die
sozialdemokratie in deutschland das ist
gut so in diesem sinne glück auf
timon gremmels hat es angesprochen bis
zu 7000 arbeitsplätze sollen eventuell
in brandenburg entstehen hat tesla chef
elon musk angekündigt nun spricht in
dieser aktuellen stunde alexander ulrich
er ist der sprecher für industriepolitik
der linksfraktion ihre rede könnte ich
viel von unterschreiben aber der letzte
satz natürlich nett dass die spd die
partei der arbeit ist da hätte man
agenda 2010 hartz iv ihrer beschäftigung
alles zugelassen
das ist das gegenteil von einer partei
der arbeit aber die aktuelle stunde
heute findet der afg entwickelt fischer
doch zum rohrkrepierer
denn wenn die afg wirklich schriftstück
danken machen würde um die arbeitsplätze
in automobilindustrie
dann dürfte man nicht den
menschgemachten klimawandel leugnen
denn wer das leugnet und damit allen
veränderungsbedarf eine absage erteilt
der gefährdet hunderttausend
arbeitsplätze in deutschland und deshalb
ist das etwas was ihm überhaupt niemand
abnimmt und dass die afg sowieso bei den
automobilbauern der kuh gesehen ist ich
bin ich mental bin früher war ich
opel-betriebsrat und ich kann mich noch
gut daran erinnern als der verschifft
führen bei einer demo in eisenach war
wurde er vertrieben von den
beschäftigten von opel dass man richtig
mal die beschäftigen von oben die angst
haben keine arbeit und kein huggel
aber richtig ist dass in der
automobilindustrie aufgrund der
veränderungen rund 100000 arbeitsplätze
wegfallen
aufgrund der veränderten
antriebstechnologien alle batterieauto
bauch hat nicht so viel wertschöpfung
wie ein verbrennungsmotor auch die ig
metall sagt da wären 100.000
arbeitsplätze wohl wegfallen aber es
werden auch neue entstehen
und deshalb ist das die entscheidende
frage volkswirtschaftlich bin ich mir
sicher wird durch diese veränderung
keine arbeitsplätze wegfallen
wenn wir die energie aus erneuerbaren
machen windkraft wieder ausbauen andere
priester endfertigungen noch mehr nach
deutschland holen werden wir am schluss
eine positive arbeitsplatz haben das ist
klar aber dafür muss noch einiges getan
werden
und deshalb sage ich ganz deutlich die
bundesregierung muss endlich mit ihrem
dogma aufwand der schwarzen null
und auch der schuldenbremse denn wenn
wir das alles fördern wollen da wird die
chancen erkennen wollen muss der staat
eine aktive industriepolitik betreiben
muss deutlich investieren in diese
mobilitäts wende das wäre richtig das
muss auch getan werden und harald meyer
und sein ministerium noch viel luft nach
oben
[Applaus]
wir haben aber und das sage ich auch
ganz deutlich wir werden regionen haben
die davon profitieren möglicherweise
auch durch die tesla ansiedlung wir
werden aber auch regionen haben die
darunter leiden durch diese veränderung
und herr luksic ich gebe ihnen recht
dass auch das saarland stark betroffen
ist in diesem band und kommen aus der
westfale sind neben dran wir sind auch
stark davon betroffen
deshalb wird es so sein wie auch bei der
kohle wir werden
strukturprobleme bekommen einigen
regionen und auch da muss der staat
ähnlich wie beim kohleausstieg diese
regionen schon politisch unterstützen
damit dieser wandel auch gestaltbar ist
die menschen machen das alles
miteinander thema machen das alles
wenn sie wissen die sind nicht die
verlierer auf die auf dieser position
und der luxus ihnen aber auch
widerspreche ist folgendes sie sagen von
denen teil das mag sein dass es so ist
aber ich bin gegen metall
gewerkschaftstag in nürnberg vor wenigen
wochen die ig metall bekennt sich
eindeutig zu den pariser
klimaschutzzielen und zwar ganz deutlich
wir müssen das auch tun und wir stehen
auch dazu dass bis 2030 jedes zweite
auto auf der straße an elektroautos sein
wird da bekennt sich die ich mal dazu
sagt aber gleichzeitig der staat muss
eine aktive industriepolitik betreiben
der stadt muss deutlich mehr investieren
in die infrastruktur der staat muss auch
den menschen helfen durch qualifizierung
und weiterbildung neue andere jobs
auszuüben deshalb bekennen wir uns als
linke ja das transfer kurzarbeitergeld
metall der vorschlag muss umgesetzt
werden damit die menschen chancen haben
andere arbeitsplätze auch aus zünden
warum diese diese aktuelle stunde auch
zu einem rohrkrepierer wird ist ja auch
die entscheidung vor zwei tagen von
tesla und egal wie darüber geredet und
das saarland hat muss sagt schade dass
nach brandenburg geht wir werden dran
gewesen
auch in rheinland pfalz hat man gedacht
jedes bundesland sagt jetzt wir werden
ab knapp dabei gewesen aber jeder
anschaffung gemüt bemüht dieses tesla
wegzubekommen
mir ist erstmal egal wo ist jetzt
hinkommt ich bin erstmal froh dass auch
diese entscheidung ja zeigt auch mit
batterie angetriebene fahrzeuge können
viele tausende arbeitsplätze schaffen
und hier wird der region von 10.000
geredet dass ein tolles signal an den
autostandort deutschland ich sage aber
auch tesla macht aber auch den deutschen
automobilherstellern klar sie haben
jahrelang die entwicklung verschlafen
die haben sich mehr am schulz oft werden
kümmert als die dem trend vorzugeben in
der elektromobilität
aber ich sage auch ganz deutlich
arbeitsplätze sind nur dann
arbeitsplätze wenn es gute arbeitsplätze
sind und kessler ist bekannt
und auch was das gut an dass kalifornien
dass er zu den größten gegnern der
amerikanischen gewerkschaften gehört hat
einen richtigen kampf gegen
amerikanische gewerkschaften nicht hohe
tesla zu denn sie investieren wollen
wenn die politische unterstützung haben
wohl bei der ansiedlung das gilt für uns
ab dem ersten tag tarifverträge ab dem
ersten tag auch mitbestimmung und
betriebsrat für das einführen will
bei uns nicht willkommen vielen dank für
die aufmerksamkeit der nächsten
[Applaus]
er ist der vorsitzender des ausschusses
für verkehr und liefert digitale
infrastruktur des bundestags herr
präsident meine damen und herren dass
die afg ein problem mit flüchtlingen hat
daran haben uns leider gewöhnen müssen
dass die afg ein problem hat mit
demokratischen gepflogenheiten mit
anstand das haben wir gestern auch noch
mit bedauern zur kenntnis nehmen müssen
aber was um himmels willen haben sie
jetzt auch noch gegen deutsche auto das
verstehen wir nun wirklich nicht meine
damen und herren
denn anders ist die debatte heute
wirklich nicht zu verstehen
ich darf noch mal für die zuschauer an
den titel erinnern
politisch verursachte arbeitsplatzabbau
in der autoindustrie
das unterstellt dass die anderen
fraktionen jenseits der afd
alle keine ahnung haben vom auto zweimal
fälle sich hin zu werden die sekunde so
als hätten sie recht aber gilt es denn
dann auch bitte schön für den chef des
unternehmens daimler bei mir im
wahlkreis helenius gilt es dann
bitteschön auch während sie den chef des
weltunternehmens bmw gilt es dann
bitteschön auch fern dies den chef von
vw gilt es für die zulieferer gilt es
für die ig metall für die
arbeitnehmervertretung wir haben so
gerade eben gehört die sind sich alle
einig und so was gibt's nun wirklich
sehen in deutschland ist das ist eine
antriebs wende braucht weil wir anders
den automobil produktionsstandort in
deutschland
retten können hören sie welches auf die
wenn sie schon nicht auf uns hört und
damit hier nicht damit ihr es gar keine
verwirrung entsteht
der kern ist doch glauben wir dass es
einen menschen verursachten klimawandel
gibt und dass auch der verkehren beitrag
dazu leisten muss und es geht dann eben
nur mit der antriebswelle oder sehen das
nicht so
ich will mich aus gründen der kürze der
zeit sie sehen es mir nach an den teil
hier des plenums richten der nicht im
finsteren mittelalter lebt und
akzeptiert dass es diesen menschen
gemachten klimawandel gibt dass er nicht
gut ist und dass wir was dagegen tun
müssen darum will ich noch mal sagen es
gibt noch einen gott sei dank
mittlerweile weitgehenden konsens in der
wissenschaft in der automobilindustrie
und ich höre dass hier so raus so
langsam auch endlich in der politik das
für kurze und für mittlere strecken beim
pkw der batteriebetriebene
elektromobilität die zukunft gehört das
heißt aber natürlich auch bei längeren
strecken bei lkws bei schiffen
verspricht der wasserstoff
beispielsweise interessante zukunft und
wir werden sicherlich auch da kannst du
uns hier gar keinen streit geben wir
hoffen doch alle dass auch synthetische
kraftstoffe
wenn wir weiter in die forschung gehen
hoffentlich auch in zukunft beitrag
leisten
aber anstatt dass wir hier wertvolle
zeit verlieren sollten wir jetzt
gemeinsam dafür ringen dass wir endlich
eine vernünftige ladeinfrastruktur bauen
das recycling strukturen haben für
batterien damit es eben künftig deutsche
autos sind die von den
produktionsbändern laufen und nicht wie
es wenn es nach der afg geht
ausländische autos sind dann ist es doch
das was passieren wird wenn auf sie und
die entscheidung von tesla die kann man
begrüßen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
mit der giga faktor aber auf der anderen
seite gehört zur wahrheit betrachtung
auch dass sie uns noch mal vor augen
geführt hat das ist keine
selbstverständlichkeit ist dass das
worauf wir zu recht stolz sind dass wir
vor unter 30 jahren das auto erfunden
haben das ist immer so bleiben muss
wir kennen das schicksal der
elektroindustrie wir wissen was mit
nokia passiert ist die das smartphone
verschoben
verschlafen haben wenn man auf sie hören
drohte schicksal für smartphones droht
uns dessen der deutschen
automobilindustrie und dafür ist diese
leitindustrie der deutschen uns nicht so
wichtig als dass wir auf die
maschinenstürmer setzen können wir
setzen auf den technischen fortschritt
und sagen nicht nein zu fortschritt und
sagen nicht nein zur zukunft die zukunft
des autos die selbst fahren die zukunft
des autos die zunehmend geteilt und sie
muss angesichts der klimakrise
selbstverständlich emissionsfrei seien
die gute nachricht wir haben alles was
man dafür braucht wir haben
hervorragende ingenieure wir haben einen
großartigen mittelstand wir haben tolle
forschungseinrichtungen und im gegensatz
zu ihnen haben wir mut den stier bei den
hörnern zu packen wir werden wir werden
das nachholen was wir in den letzten
jahren verschlafen haben und dann werden
wir zeigen mit german mut produzieren
wir auch in zukunft deutsche autos ich
weiß das ist schwer für eine partei die
sie auf der schüren von hass und schüren
von ängsten da sich besonders
spezialisiert hat das ist eine große
herausforderung für sie einfach den rest
des hauses sollte gelten dass es unsere
aufgabe als politikerinnen und politiker
ist den menschen mut zu machen mut dass
es eine große herausforderung ist aber
erst der transformation der
automobilindustrie auch eine chance
steht meine damen meine herren
der große demokrit wusste schon mut
steht am anfang des handels glück am
ende hinter
cem özdemir von bündnis 90 die grünen
war das nächste redner in dieser
aktuellen stunde zum möglichen
arbeitsplatzabbau in der
automobilindustrie ist matthias heider
cdu csu fraktion der stunde der afd
und ich stelle mal fest es ist schon
nicht besonders klug nicht mit der
technischen entwicklung gehen zuvor aber
die ängste von arbeitnehmern und ihren
familien zu schüren und history mit
zahlen zu betreiben das ist
verantwortungslos
was die afd
auch nicht verstanden hat wir leben hier
in deutschland nicht auf der insel der
glückseligen auf einer abgeschotteten
insel sondern wirtschaft im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
funktioniert mit wettbewerb und das ist
ein globaler wettbewerb und wie sie an
den entscheidungen von enden machst
sehen dieser wettbewerb steht bei uns
vor der tür und wir müssen dem etwas
entgegen halten und wenn es etwas klüger
es gibt als offen zu sein für
verschiedene antriebe in der
automobiltechnologie dann ist das das
gebot der stunde diese technischen
entwicklungen in unserem eigenen land
voranzutreiben und dazu kommt liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das der
menschengemachte klimawandel uns
besondere anstrengungen abverlangt dazu
gehört dass wir selbst mit produkten mit
dienstleistungen an den markt kommen und
nicht den anderen dabei den vorsprung
lassen
in asien werden derzeit quantensprünge
bei der entwicklung der antriebe gemacht
china führt bei der e-mobilität japan
führt im markt der wasserstoff antriebe
der zahlen insbesondere china und die
usa sie sehen an dem genannten
unternehmen das hier in brandenburg
investieren will zielen sie auf einen
deutschen absatzmarkt und wenn wir uns
mal die neuzulassungen beispielsweise
beim diesel beim volkswagen ansehen dann
gibt es da eine volatilität an der sie
auch die gesellschaftliche diskussion in
unserem land nachvollziehen können und
ich glaube wir haben immerhin wieder
zulassungszahlen von rund 16.000 dem
monat september gehabt es kommt eben
stark darauf an wofür für welchen zweck
will ich ein solches fahrzeug als
verbraucher kaufen und deshalb ist es
ein guter rat technologieoffen zu sein
genauso wie der staatssekretär thomas
bareiß das vorhin beschrieben hat mal am
und herren die zukunft der
automobilwirtschaft liegt in einer
deutschen schlüsselindustrie es ist auch
die zukunft des mittelstandes vieler
familien betriebe darunter
und es geht um zahlreiche arbeitsplätze
die wir mit mehr wettbewerbsfähigkeit in
unserem land schützen müssen
technologieoffenheit gehört aber auch
auf neue antriebe und neue energien die
dafür gesetzt werden wasserstoff und
brennstoffzelle biodiesel methan ethanol
flüssiggas das alles spielt eine
wichtige rolle und wenn wir uns jetzt
mal ein bisschen von der branche wird
bewegen hören sie nur mal moment zum
überlegen damit in den sechzigerjahren
was da ein wandel etwa vom
lebensmitteleinzelhändler zum discounter
an bewegungen erbracht hat heute haben
wir 16.000 discounter in deutschland
schauen sie mal auf die 90er jahre vom
stationären einzelhandel zum online
handel mittlerweile werden zehn prozent
53 milliarden euro im online-handel der
wirtschaft
und wenn sie gerne das technische
beispiel noch mal hören worden wenn sie
etwa verfolgen den wandel
von der glühlampe wird zur led dann ist
daran gut abzulesen dass wir innerhalb
eines zeitraums von mehr als zehn jahren
dazu gekommen sind dass wir jetzt
erhebliche energie in den haushalten
durch andere beleuchtungsmittel
einsparen können und meine damen und
herren das ist ohne große brüche in der
branche der elektrotechnik
vonstattengegangen im gegenteil es hat
mehr wertschöpfung gegeben es hat mehr
qualität gegeben und es hat einen wandel
in der arbeitswelt gegeben die die
arbeitnehmer genauso mitgetragen haben
wie die unternehmer meine damen und
herren anpassungen von dienstleistungen
anpassungen von produkten das kombiniert
mit den richtigen förderinstrumenten die
alle schon genannt worden sind das ist
eine strategie die wir im 21 jahrhundert
haben muss wir müssen uns gut aufstellen
und wir müssen für diesen wandel auch
bereit sein uns zu bewegen
und wir müssen die arbeitnehmer und ihre
familien dabei mitnehmen ängste zu schön
ist der falsche weg
aber rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen in
unserem land in dem gewährleistet ist
dass dieser wandel eine gute zukunft
hinten kann das meine damen und herren
ist das ziel dass jede politik haben
muss auch wie dieser bundesregierung
herzlichen dank sagt matthias heider von
der unionsfraktion
die afg hat ja diese aktuelle stunde
hier beantragt und auch der nächste
sprecher kommt von der fraktion wird
spanien ist obmann im ausschuss für
wirtschaft und energie
aktuell geht eine ankündigung von
massenentlassungen in der
automobilindustrie durch das land und
die menschen sind zu recht verunsichert
und viele fragen sich wie kann das sein
ist unsere industrie nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig diese massenentlassung
und die krise in der automobilindustrie
sind politisch verursacht und zwar von
einer eu verordnung die autoindustrie
wird politisch gezwungen
elektromobilität umzusetzen höchste mir
und das wissen sie ganz genau und viele
will jubeln seit gestern die angebliche
entscheidung von tesla eine neue fabrik
im umland von berlin anzusiedeln und
bestenfalls bis zu 6000 arbeitsplätze zu
schaffen
sie verschweigen jedoch dass dieses werk
vor allem deshalb hier entstehen soll
weil hier in deutschland unvorstellbare
summen an subventionen für diesen
produktionsstandort fließen werden und
elektromobilität unverantwortlich
subventioniert wird
wir sehen dass sie den fehler der
förderung der solarindustrie nun
wiederholen und das steuergeld der hart
arbeitenden bevölkerung hier verbrennen
für ihre ideologischen spielereien
sie verschweigen auch dass das
elektroauto oder dass ich für das
elektroauto bei seinem derzeitigen
technischen entwicklungsstand überhaupt
gar keinen markt gibt die menschen
wollen keine elektroautos und dieser
markt auch in norwegen dieser markt wird
nur durch verbote von konkurrierender
technologie und subventionen des
elektroantriebes von ihnen künstlich
geschaffen und von dem verkehrs und
umweltausschuss wurde letztes jahr
experten und gewerkschaftsvertreter jahr
von der ig metall angehört und die haben
ihnen diese krise heute genau
vorhergesagt es sind sätze gefallen wie
das könnte das ende der deutschen
automobilindustrie sein
sie wurden gewarnt und es war ihm klar
was kommen wird sie wussten es und sie
von den grünen sie wollten sogar noch
verschärfungen der verbrauchs regeln
haben und sich von der regierung sie
haben es billigend in kauf genommen
am 23 märz letzten jahres hat die afd in
diesem haus anbieten einspruch gegen
diese eu verordnung und die es hier geht
einzulegen
das ist die wurzel allen übels wir
wollten öffentlich darüber sprechen
welche konsequenzen diese für unsere
industrie durch diese verordnung wohnen
doch sie alle inklusive der fdp haben
eine öffentliche debatte darüber von der
tagesordnung gewischt
sie wollten nicht dass die menschen in
diesem land erfahren was durch ihre
politik auf sie zukommt eine hair by
fantasierte verkehrswende und das tanzen
von verblendeten menschen auf der straße
werden die familien hunderttausender
betroffener in der automobilindustrie
jedenfalls nicht ernähren und speziell
der emotionale kreuzzug gegen das
automobil den sie ja alle betreiben und
der von den grünen und den linken
befeuert wird
der ist unverantwortlich für eine
moderne industriegesellschaft mit der
definition emissionsfreie fahrzeuge wie
sie in der eu verordnung finden
verhindern bürokraten und juristen
bürokraten und juristen in berlin und in
brüssel dass ingenieure überhaupt
ergebnisoffen nach technischen lösungen
suchen können und genau deshalb
herrschte mehr weil die bürokratie und
die politik diese lösungen verhindern
muss die autoindustrie sich so
entscheiden wie das heute ist und sie
von der fdp das hat mich ja jetzt
gewundert dass ich auf einmal für
synthetische kraftstoffe sein wollen
oder zumindest hier sagen sie haben
unseren antrag für synthetische
kraftstoffe im ausschuss genau wie alle
an
parteien hier abgelehnt und weil sie den
abgelehnt haben ist das was sie hier
machen
in wirklichkeit interessiert sie das
alles gar nicht die versuchen nur in der
öffentlichkeit ein gutes bild zu
erwecken sie haben unseren antrag zu
synthetischen kraftstoffen und mehr
wettbewerb um diese verordnung zu
erfüllen abgelehnt und das ist ein fakt
das kann jeder in den protokollen
nachlesen
und wissen sie was er kommt ja noch mal
ins plenum und wenn sie jetzt dafür sind
da können sie diesem antrag ja zu
stimmen
wie werden die namentliche abstimmung
beantragen ja genau und da können die
menschen in diesem land die menschen in
diesem land können dann sehen wer von
ihnen hier sitzt auf dem blauen zipfeln
für den verlust ihrer arbeitsplätze
verantwortlich ist und ich hoffe ich
hoffe dass die menschen das dann auch
bei ihrer nächsten wahl berücksichtigen
werden wir stehen zum automobil und zu
der deutschen automobilindustrie und sie
alle haben diese arbeitsplätze verraten
vielen dank dirk spanien von der afg
fraktion erst obmann im ausschuss für
wirtschaft und energie und in diesem
ausschuss sitzt auch der nächste redner
falko mohrs von der spd fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident meine damen
und herren wir erleben dass die auf dem
mal wieder alles schlecht redet angst
schürt und das fängt beim titel dieser
aktuellen stunde an
das ist wirklich sowas von billig und
herr spanien
ich habe ja mit meinen mitarbeiterinnen
mitarbeiter volkswagen in drei schichten
autos gebaut da haben sie wahrscheinlich
gerade mal den sessel weil sich im büro
warmgehalten wissen wir ja wissen sie
eigentlich was wir mit leuten in unserer
halle gemacht hätten die so wenig ahnung
vom automobilbau haben wie sie die
rausgeschmissen
so ist die realität in spanien und
vielleicht das letzte regen sich noch
gar nicht so gar nicht so auch
kolleginnen kollegen wird noch schlimmer
für sie sind das letzte was die
beschäftigten der automobilindustrie
brauchen das meine damen und herren ist
die afd
und wenn sie mir nicht glauben wenn die
mir nicht glauben dann hören sie doch
gleich noch fehlt und werner zum
beispiel vorstand bei volkswagen gesagt
sie erkennt bei der afd
kein zukunftsbild alles was sie erkennt
ist vergangenheit und dahin möchte sie
nicht zurück das ist die realität ein
hin und her
sie leben in der vergangenheit sie leben
in der technologischen vergangenheit sie
wollen jens errichten und das ist gift
für jede industrie die auf der
weltweiten märkte angewiesen ist meine
damen und herren so sieht's aus mit der
afd
und wenn sie mir das immer noch nicht
glauben dann nehmen sie vielleicht mal
zur kenntnis dass sowohl das unternehmen
volkswagen wie die ig metall und der
betriebsrat sich aktiv darum bemühen die
volkswagen halle in braunschweig wo sie
ihren parteitag abhalten davon zu
überzeugen den namen der halle zu
erinnern sie mich nicht bereit sind ihre
namen volkswagen für die afg und ihren
parteitag zur verfügung zu stehen
das meine damen und herren das ist die
realität ich hoffe dass am 30
während sie ihren parteitag dort
abhalten wollen möglichst viele auf der
straße sind ich gehört zu den
aufrufenden
da werden wir mal zeigen dass die
arbeitnehmer und arbeitnehmerinnen
automobilindustrie sie überhaupt nicht
wollen und ich kenne den stresstest den
die automobilindustrie durchmachen muss
aus digitalisierung aus der veränderung
der antriebsstränge ich kenne das von
milliarden notwendig sind um standorte
umzubauen für forschung und entwicklung
natürlich das ist die realität was aber
eine industrie braucht die sich in der
veränderung der transformation befindet
es doch nicht dass es menschen gibt die
angst schüren sondern dass es menschen
gibt die die unternehmen und die
mitarbeiter und mitarbeiter die hand
nehmen der veränderung die sagen wir
qualifizieren euch damit ihr auch morgen
noch im kopf hat die sagen sie sind
bereit die infrastruktur aufzubauen
die bereiten einen masterplan dafür in
die wege zu leiten
das mag sein dass hier der unterschied
zwischen masterplan und planwirtschaft
nicht verstehen aber was bringt es denn
meine damen und herren finden sie hier
fordern dass wir nichts in den
infrastrukturausbau der e mobilität
investieren und dann am ende nämlich
genau die fahrzeuge die dort gebaut
werden gebaut werden müssen eben keine
abnehmer finden weil die sage ich weiß
gar nicht wo ich laden soll das ist doch
die realität von ihnen sie verweigern
den masterplan sie verweigern jede
politische steuerung sie leben in der
zeit von 1933 bis 45 aber in der zeit
den biotechnologisch stehen geblieben
und wenn sie dann jetzt hier irgendwie
so tun dass sie die arbeiterpartei
werden liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
jetzt liebe nämlich zurück von der ard
sie sind und das ist die realität gegen
die mindest auszubildenden vergütungen
gegen mietpreis bremsen gegen
tarifverträge die sie als sozialismus
abtun
sie sind dafür dass die sachgrundlose
befristung beibehalten wird das ist doch
ihre politik sieht man rentenkonzept
aber tun sich hier so als ob sie so
einen anstrich mal über ziehen könnten
und die sozial partei werden
der spanier es geht darum dass die so
tun als ob sie für die beschäftigten
reden das tun sie nicht sie reden für
ihren nationalistischen eliten herr
spanien das ist die realität
also meine damen und herren was wegen
dieser aktuellen stunde erlebt haben ist
eine plakative überschrift die angst
macht reden von ihnen die angst machen
sollen aber bestenfalls lustig sind von
ahnungslosigkeit strotzen die selber
keinen einzigen vorschlag präsentieren
sie nehmen die beschäftigten der
automobilindustrie in geiselhaft und
dass das können wir beim besten willen
nicht durchgelassen das werden wir nicht
durchgehen lassen ich bin froh dass
menschen wie sie hier keine
verantwortung übernehmen das wird so
bleiben dafür stehen wir dafür kämpfen
wir als spd mit der überwiegende
mehrheit in diesem haus in diesem sinne
alles gute glück auf es ist ja eine
durchaus emotionale debatte hierüber die
möglichen arbeitsplätze die wegfallen
könnten in der automobilindustrie weil
natürlich auch die automobilindustrie
sich verändern muss und schauen muss wie
sie mit dem wandel von benzinern und
diese zu alternativen antrieben hin klar
kommt während haltlos spricht jetzt von
der unionsfraktion abgeordnete der
münchner des münchner wahlkreises in dem
die firmen bmw und ein liegen
wahrscheinlich training geht er als
erster für die arbeitnehmer und die
unternehmen kämpfen würde denn die
automobilindustrie ist eine
schlüsselindustrie in unserem land mit
einer enormen image wirkung weltweit
aber darum geht es ihnen sicherlich
nicht sie betreiben doch nur schwarz
malerei am arbeitsplatz ängste zu
schüren
weil sie denken es würde ihnen
wählerstimmen bringen
aber glauben sie mir die bürgerinnen und
bürger durchschauen
ihre motive die deutsche
automobilwirtschaft muss sich
herausforderungen wie neuen technologien
einem strukturwandel und einem globalen
wettbewerbs fällen
wir wollen die automobilwirtschaft dabei
unterstützen fit zu sein für diese
zukunfts herausforderungen einer sich
weltweit wandel mobilität anders als sie
es den bürgern glauben machen wollen ist
aber klimaschutz kein gegensatz zu
automobilität wir waren natürlich nicht
den ast absägen auf dem wir
industriepolitisch sitzen
wir brauchen vielmehr einen neustart für
die zukunft cd automobil saubere
technologien sind dabei notwendige
kernkompetenzen synthetische kraftstoffe
in modernen batterieforschung und
wasserstoff als energieträger der
zukunft
und weil sie auch in bayern von
einzelnen marken und flugblätter
verteilen ließen sage ich ihnen mal als
bayerischer abgeordneter was zb der
freistaat bayern ganz konkret macht
erstens aus dem forschungszentrum
synthetische kraftstoffe in straubing
wird ein nationales referenzzentrum der
campus wird um vier neue lehrstühle
aufgestockt und mittelfristig wird eine
neue power to liquid anlage installiert
dort soll synthetische kraftstoffe
entwickelt werden
zweitens zusätzlich zum bundesprojekt in
münster investiert waren in ein
bayerisches batterie netzwerk ziel ist
die entwicklung einer neuen generation
von klimafreundlichen und
leistungsfähigeren batterien für die
elektromobilität drittens gemeinsam mit
vagen rücken tag soll in nördlingen und
ellwangen
neue batterieproduktion mit der
industrie entstehen und schließlich
viertens wird ein neues wasserstoff
zentrum in nürnberg entstehen um diese
technologie zwischen hochschule und
wirtschaft zu vernetzen bayern als
automobilstandort und deutschland als
ganzes ist gut aufgestellt
also kein grund für die höheren
botschaften und weil sie gerne den
zusammenhang zwischen klimaschutz in
einem arbeitsplatz-abbau herstellen
würden
das klimapaket ist ja noch gar nicht in
kraft
das widerspruch wird deutlich am
beispiel der schaeffler-gruppe die
einzelnen maßnahmen zur vermeidung
betriebsbedingter kündigungen aufgrund
volatile märkte und dem track
technologie technologischen
veränderungsdruck bereits im frühjahr
2009 10 verkündet also noch gar nicht
bekannt war welche regelungen kommen
würden entsprechend die maßnahmen zu
ergreifen
die wahrheit ist doch die technologische
entwicklung geht immer weiter und sie
können als unternehmer nicht nur aus der
schublade verkaufen sondern sie müssen
das verkaufen was der markt abfragen und
ich bin etwas enttäuscht auch über die
fdp
die ihnen so waren auch das wort redet
und das wort planwirtschaft in den mund
nimmt
ich denke unternehmen unternehmerisch
tätig zu sein ist etwas anders
wirtschaft heißt wettbewerb wettbewerb
einstellen auf neue verfahren und
innovationen innovation heißt
fortschritt die elektromobilität ist
dabei nicht die einzige aber ein
entscheidender weg kein hirngespinst
deutsche politiker ein blick nach china
wo ich als unternehmer selbst tätig bin
aber auch nach kalifornien zeigt es doch
wir reden von einem globalen trend
und da der export für die deutsche
automobilwirtschaft eminent wichtig ist
muss sie sich den globalen
herausforderungen anforderungen stellen
den trend aufgreifen ja den trend
vorgeben wird die politik müssen beim
technologie wandel unterstützen
das ist auch der grund warum der bund
die batteriezellen forschung massiv
voran bringen technologisch ist nicht zu
leugnen ist das ein elektromotor weniger
teil hat einen verbrennungs und
verbrennungsmotor aber wir haben auch
keine röhren fahren sie hier mehr
weil sich die technologische entwicklung
weiter entwickelt hat und deshalb haben
wir heute trotzdem ansehen möchte auch
da noch einmal darauf hinweisen dass die
neuen technologien durchaus neue
arbeitsplätze schaffen wie jetzt zum
beispiel auch tesla in berlin
insbesondere auch mit dem ingenieur und
designzentrum was immerhin 10.000
arbeitsplätze bringt ist das politisch
vor arbeitsplatzabbau
ich denke nicht aber natürlich sollten
wir nicht allein auf elektromobilität
setzen sondern auch auf andere
technologien kurier von der union sei
die zuversicht in die automobile zukunft
optimismus statt pessimismus das
unterscheidet unterscheidet uns von
ihnen
wir bringen in deutschland voran danke
für die sp fraktion passwort der kollege
tochter martin rosemann
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren
politisch verursachte arbeitsplatzabbau
in der automobilindustrie
allein der titel zeigt doch die
realitätsverweigerung der afd
sie meinen offenbar die deutsche und die
europäische politik was sie überhaupt
nicht erkennen ist die abhängigkeit vom
weltmarkt ist die tatsache dass
weichenstellungen vor allem in china an
vorgenommen werden
ich will meine damen und herren dass
auch die autos von morgen in deutschland
auch in baden württemberg gebaut werden
und dann müssen wir uns auf dem
weltmarkt einstellen dann müssen wir auf
innovationen setzen dann müssen wir
offen sein für neues meine damen und
herren die klimaziele sind nicht etwa
eine laune der politik im globalen
rahmen entscheiden sie über das
überleben der menschheit hier in
deutschland gilt dass wir unseren
beitrag leisten müssen und vor allem
sind wir das einzige industrieland das
gleichzeitig aus kohle und atomenergie
aussteigt und dabei wollen wir
industrieland bleiben das müssen wir
zeigen und gleichzeitig dass es sozial
gerecht zugeht dabei natürlich natürlich
bedeutet das einen großen
transformationsprozess aber nicht
übrigens nicht nur bei den neuen
antriebstechniken sondern wir haben das
thema digitalisierung durch
digitalisierung verändert sich die
arbeit in großem stil und nicht nur die
automobilhersteller selbst sondern vor
allem die zulieferer sind doch davon
betroffen das gilt übrigens auch für die
handelskriege wollen sie denn für die
handelskriege jetzt auch noch die
verantwortung bei der bundesregierung
suchen also ich finde damit haben wir
einen
am allerwenigsten zu tun also
also wir haben eine ganze menge von
herausforderungen tatsächlich gesehen
dass bereits auch bei den zulieferern
hat die kurzarbeit zugenommen wir haben
tatsächlich die ankündigung von stellen
aber in einigen bereichen und ich meine
da ist jetzt vorausschauende politik
gefragt vorausschauende aktive
arbeitsmarktpolitik vor allem müssen wir
dafür sorgen dass wir nicht gleichzeitig
fachkräftemangel und arbeitslosigkeit
produzieren und das werden wir mit
sicherheit nicht schaffen mit einer
politik die so tut als könne alles so
bleiben wie es früher einmal war sondern
nur mit einer politik die die
beschäftigten im wandel unterstützt
jeden und jede einzelne und das heißt
arbeitsmarktpolitik die schutz und
chancen im wandel bietet das heißt alle
mitzunehmen jeden einzelnen unterstützen
den sozialstaat als partner der sich
darum kümmert dass alle bei diesen
wandel mit kommen und es geht um
individuelle unterstützung schon im
arbeitsleben damit arbeitslosigkeit erst
gar nicht entsteht ihr sprechen vom
recht auf arbeit und es ist klar weiter
bildung ist der schlüssel der schlüssel
dafür dass die beschäftigten von heute
die arbeit von morgen machen können und
wir haben da angefangen wir haben das
qualifizierungs chancen gesetz
beschlossen wie den wir perspektiven für
alle schaffen wohl nur diesen weg meine
damen und herren
diesen legt den wollen wir weitergehen
erstens auch wenn nicht nur einzelne
beschäftigte betroffen sind sondern
große teile der belegschaften zweitens
wenn beschäftigte keine perspektive im
eigenen unternehmen mehr haben
und drittens es geht darum auch brücken
zu bauen wenn unternehmen und branchen
in die krise kommen und deswegen müssen
wir instrumente wie kurzarbeit und
transfergesellschaften in viel stärkerem
maße nutzt
um die leute heute schon zu
qualifizieren für die aufgaben von
morgen also für weiterbildung und
deshalb deshalb meine damen und herren
es ist gut dass robert heil unserer
arbeits und sozialminister des arbeit
von morgen gesetz angekündigt hat
genauso wichtig ist es aber dass wir
diesen wandel gemeinsam gestalten
arbeitnehmer und arbeitgeber deswegen
ist die sozialpartnerschaft in
deutschland so richtig in jedem
einzelnen betrieben meine damen und
herren
klar ist die risiken im wandel sind
unterschiedlich verteilt und deshalb
werden wir die herausforderungen nur
gemeinsam und solidarisch bewältigen und
dafür stehen wir als sozialdemokratische
partei in deutschland ein ich danke
ihnen für die aufmerksamkeit sagt martin
rosemann von der spd-fraktion der
vorletzte redner in dieser aktuellen
stunde ist uwe schummer
er ist der vorsitzende der
arbeitnehmergruppe der cdu csu fraktion
zum einen wenn von rechtsaußen
kritisiert wird dass das was wir alles
tun alles so planwirtschaft ist wenn von
linksaußen gesagt wird wir tun zu wenig
es wird viel zu wenig staatliche
eingriffe organisiert glaube ich dass
wir im zentrum der gesellschaft in der
mitte genau richtig aufgehoben sind bei
der sozialen marktwirtschaft wenn sich
der staat auch eine aufgabe hat soziale
marktwirtschaft bedeutet eben mehr als
markt der sozial begriff umfasst auch
die ökologische frage auch die frage der
verantwortung für die schöpfung
klimaschutz und industriearbeit wir
wollen wir zusammen führen wir wollen
versöhnen da wo andere polarisieren und
radikalisieren nur wer perspektiven
zeigt wer wird auf menschen auf dauer
für das wirtschaften überzeugen können
und es gibt gute beispiele was genannt
wurden die investition von tesla hier in
berliner brandenburger raum mit 10.000
arbeitsplätzen das ist der vw in zwickau
die 1,2 milliarden
euro investiert haben für 8000
arbeitsplätze 13.000 trainingstage für
den umstieg auf die elektromobilität für
die dort beschäftigten und vw chef
ulrich sagt als vorstandsvorsitzender
wir wollen die vormachtstellung als
autobauer weltweit verteidigen nicht
zurückschaut sondern vorwärts strategie
ist deren konzept anders als hier
rechtsaußen in einem weiteren neuen werk
will vw mehr als die hälfte seiner
elektroautos für den chinesischen markt
produzieren wir wissen in ruhrgebiet
dass kommunen elektrobusse kaufen wollen
aber keine deutschen anbieter finden
da wären aufträge hilfreich und sinnvoll
aber wir können nicht liefern und
deshalb muss dieser rückstand aufgeholt
werden
autozulieferer schaeffler baut in baden
württemberg und auch hier sollen 10.000
arbeitsplätze neu geschaffen werden das
heißt nicht ein weg viele wege die wir
beschreiten müssen den verbrenner der
weiter optimiert wird den einsatz von
wasserstoff zur herstellung
synthetischer kraftstoffe oder für die
brennstoffzelle
es geht uns nicht um den ausstieg beim
auto wir wollen den umstieg in eine
produktion die dauerhaft zukunftsfähig
ist made in germany ist ein gütesiegel
beste ingenieurtechnik langlebige
produkte maximale leistung bei minimalem
ressourcenverbrauch angekratzt wurde
dieses made in germany durch kurzatmige
manager die mit einer software die
öffentlichkeit und auch die eigenen
unternehmen und kunden betrogen haben
und das ist langfristiger schaden nur
wir politisch darauf reagieren
miteinander und wer arbeitet auf dauer
sichern will
dann ist der schlüssel hierzu klare und
faire produkte qualifizierung um soziale
wirtschaftliche und ökologische
herausforderungen zu meistern der
autogipfel im bundeskanzleramt hat mit
den unternehmen mit den gewerkschaften
und auch mit den weiteren verbänden gute
impulse gezeigt wir wollen qualifizieren
statt entlassen und von daher ist das
auch ein punkt mit dem wir den wandel
begleiten aber natürlich nicht
planwirtschaftlich organisieren können
probleme angehen ist der unterschied und
die alternative als wissenschaft und
probleme zu leugnen und wenn der
abgeordnete hilfe von der ard im
tagesspiegel die steile these vertritt
menschen hätten überhaupt keinen
einfluss auf die temperatur
es gehe um eine natürliche erwärmung der
eiszeit
dann frage ich mich was hat er geraucht
kollege guy lange wenn sie die taktische
richtung vorgeben in der welt am sonntag
dass sie nach dem euro oder zuwanderung
nun die klimapolitik an den pranger
stellen wollen und ihr ziel ist raus aus
allen verträgen agitation stadt wahrheit
und angst ihr ständiger begleiter ich
kenne noch sehr persönlich weiter weil
man weiter weil man war der erste
umweltminister in deutschland im
kabinett helmut kohl und die hat das
eine der ersten maßnahmen ein großer
liberaler christdemokrat beispielsweise
damals 1986 die änderung der kfz steuer
zu unterstützung schadstoffarmer autos
weiter entwickelt ich kann nur sagen er
wäre entsetzt herr gauland würde er
ihren moralischen politischen niedergang
noch erleben
sie sollten sich schämen für uns gilt
kurzarbeit mit qualifizierung hat in
2009 aus der wirtschaftskrise geführt
für uns zählt wir haben in der agentur
für arbeit 24 milliarden euro rücklagen
wir sind auch finanziell gerüstet für
eine mögliche krise die wir begleiten
können die wir abwehren können und der
stärkste schutz der beschäftigten in der
automobilindustrie beileibe nicht die
fdp aber die soziale partnerschaft das
hier gewerkschaften arbeitgebern
vernünftig miteinander zusammenarbeiten
auch die mitbestimmung unser ziel
sicherheit im wandel
diese herausforderung ist politisch wir
gehen sie mit den unternehmen mit den
verbrauchern mit den beschäftigten und
der letzte redner in dieser debatte zu
arbeitsplatzabbau in der
automobilindustrie ist christoph ploß er
sitzt im ausschuss für verkehr und
digitale infrastruktur für die
unionsfraktion als letzter
debattenredner ist man kann man ein
bisschen lob verteilen an die guten
debattenbeiträge und natürlich auch
kritik äußern und während meine kollegen
von der cdu csu fraktion natürlich
ausschließlich lob verdient haben so
muss ich doch etwas verwunderung zum
ausdruck bringt über einige aussagen vor
allem von der afg aber auch von der
linkspartei und den grünen
wir hören von ihnen hier liebe kollegen
der ard eine auffassung dass man
eigentlich gar nichts machen müsste
sie sagen angesichts des klimawandels
angesichts der klimaschutzziele und der
transformation im mobilitätssektor
müsste gar nichts passieren und wie sie
darauf kommen können angesichts der
offenkundigen entwicklung das ist mir
wirklich schleierhaft und ich kann
deswegen sagen am ende wird genau diese
haltung arbeitsplätze in der
automobilindustrie kosten da geht der
alte spruch wenn ich mit der zeit geht
der geht mit der zeit und ich glaube es
würden sich einige hier wünschen dass
das für sie im parlament zu trifft aber
im gegensatz im gegensatz zu ihm haben
dass alle in der automobilindustrie und
ich glaube auch die meisten hier im
hause verstanden und wir haben auf der
anderen seite
die linkspartei einige kollegen auch der
grünen die eine weltuntergangsstimmung
verbreiten und die allein auf
batteriebetriebene elektromobilität
setzen und die sich gegen innovative
neue ideen wie wasserstoff und
synthetische kraftstoffe wie es
aussprechen und ich sage beide ansätze
die wären falsche unser land und wir
werden als cdu csu fraktion deswegen an
anderen weg geben wir werden neue
technologien in deutschland entwickeln
bzw
die rahmenbedingungen dafür schaffen und
wir wollen damit arbeitsplätze sichern
letztlich mit technologien
exportschlager für die welt entwickeln
und ich habe hier leider außer von den
kollegen der cdu csu kaum von jemandem
gehört wie stellen wir uns eigentlich
die mobilität in deutschland im jahr 20
30 und 20 35 vor
wenn wir hier über unser
zukunftskonzepte sprechen und für uns
ist dabei ganz klar
neben einem zum beispiel gut ausgebauten
u und s bahn system da wird das auto in
deutschland immer noch eine große rolle
in der mobilität spielen natürlich vor
allem im ländlichen bereich aber wir
werden immer mehr autos haben in 10 15
jahren die klimafreundlich unterwegs
sind die immer leiser unterwegs sind und
wir werden autos auf den straßen haben
wo die menschen nicht mehr selbst fahren
sondern wo die menschen gefahren werden
wo es sind digital vernetzten verkehr
gibt der klima schont ist der effizient
ist der staus vermeidet und wo auch
tödliche verkehrsunfälle der
vergangenheit angehören das ist das
konzept an dem wir als cdu csu fraktion
arbeiten wir arbeiten aber auch daran
die automobilindustrie zu stärken indem
wir die ladeinfrastruktur in deutschland
mit jedem jahr weiter verbessern indem
wir neue ladepunkte schaffen indem wir
wasserstoff tankstellen schaffen und
indem wir auf synthetische kraftstoffe
fördern denn es wird natürlich völlig
unterschiedliche antriebe geben in den
großstädten das wurde hier schon
angesprochen mit einem beitrag da werden
wahrscheinlich mehr bei der rhi
getrieben elektroautos unterwegs sein
aber gerade aber gerade dort wo große
reichweiten
erforderlich sind da brauchen wir auch
wasserstoff und die synthetischen
kraftstoffen und deswegen ist der
technologieoffenen ansatz der cdu csu
fraktion genau der richtige weg und am
ende müssen die verbraucher auf die wahl
haben zwischen den verschiedenen
technologien wir wollen das gar nicht
als cdu csu entscheiden was die menschen
für einen auto sich kaufen sollen dann
muss es mehrere möglichkeiten geben aber
wir wollen die politischen
rahmenbedingungen ändern denn ganz ganz
wichtig ist bei der mobilität der
zukunft dass wir von einer ölbasierten
mobilität auf eine strom basierte
mobilität kommen und um das zu erreichen
da brauchen wir eben die steuerlichen
förderung die ladeinfrastruktur
forschung von wasserstoff und den
synthetischen kraftstoffen wir wollen
strom günstiger machen deswegen ist auch
so gut dass wir die stromsteuer senken
werden und wir wollen deutsche
technologie entwickeln wo wir dann
exportschlager haben um in sonnen und
windreichen regionen dieser welt
deutsche technologie zum einsatz kommen
zu lassen dort wasserstoff zu
produzieren oder die synthetische
kraftstoffe und die ersten erfolge der
politik der bundesregierung steffen
bilger sitzt da auf der regierungsbank
thomas bareiß
die kann man doch sehen die giga factory
von tesla die hier erwähnt wurde oder
die neue fabrik von vw in zwickau auf
gerade in den regionen des landes wo wir
enorm bedarf haben da kommt bewegung
rein sagt entstehen arbeitsplätze und
das gelingt die transformation und
deswegen es ist auch so gut dass wir mit
dem nächsten bundeshaushalt gerade
produktionsanlagen für strom basierte
kraftstoffe und biokraftstoffe fördern
dass wir wasserstoff und
brennstoffzellentechnologie fördern und
dass wir die lade und tank infrastruktur
für alternative kraftstoffe fördern das
wird der weg sein den wir in den
nächsten jahren weitergehen und dann bin
ich auch sehr überzeugt dann werden wir
neue arbeitsplätze schaffen dann werden
wir die klimaschutzziele
und dann wird sind wir auf dem besten
wege wenn es über die mobilität der
zukunft geht herzlichen dank ja das war
dann die aktuelle stunde von christoph
ploß der sagt dass wir auf dem besten
wege sind bis zu vier stimmen aus der
afg die gesagt haben dass hier
arbeitsplätze vernichtet wurden war das
doch eine recht große bandbreite